Allyson's in Fort Wayne Indiana hey
Allison welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve
how can Chris and I help okay my husband
and I are in what I think you would call
crisis mode he lost his job
December 15th of this past year and of
course two months prior to that we
started following Total Money Makeover
had our budget done he lost his job he
just recently got a is gonna be getting
a job offer but it's for significantly
less than what he was making what was he
making it was about sixty thousand a
year and we're now going down to about
twenty five thousand a year
he has a background in the IT field he's
this is going to be a security position
that he's taking he's also ex-military
and we're in a very rural area so it's
very difficult to find positions and
he's been doing what he can interviewing
and has had interviews and things
haven't panned out since since December
why have you not moved because we just
bought our property two years ago
I don't care hand and hand he has
inheritance invested in a white-tailed
deer farm so we've got we're on a farm
and the time is not right that's not
something he's willing to give up we're
coming in on your for now which you're
for is when you start to the deer start
to produce enough income to cover their
expenses for the following year plus a
little bit of profit but my question
comes to when we do our four wall four
walls and we have them covered we know
that we need to get second jobs we know
that we need to sell things to make
extra income to pay debt down we're in
the process of doing that if in the
process of doing that we still do not
have
enough to make the minimum payments on
our debt how do we handle that how much
debt do you have probably about seventy
five thousand one there is a personal
line of credit at the bank credit cards
there's no student loans we own our
vehicles how much did he invest in the
white-tailed deer farm probably about a
hundred and twenty thousand and the the
farm is a piously a piece of raw ground
that's correct that's wooded and what is
it worth today it is not wooded it's not
a wooded area
it's we live on 12 acres and about half
of that about five acres of it contained
beer pens with fencing and graze area
and so forth
we bought our property for a hundred and
fifty five thousand two years ago I
don't know what it's worth and you paid
100 you paid cash for it
I'm sorry but investing over thousand
dollars in deer or in the land in the
deer the deer the building materials for
the fencing so you're raising these deer
like you raised cattle you're not
raising them as a hunting preserve no
you raise them that is part of it as a
part of these twelve acres part no part
of the process was raising them is that
then you turn around and you sell the
Bucks when there are two three four
years old to the hunting preserves I'll
just so that's where the money comes in
from but it's a five year process by
year three you should be breaking even
you know so forth so we're really only a
few months away and we have very strong
projections of the deer themselves
anything we sell this fall covering all
of their expenses next year with some
leftover so he's he's really not wanting
to so he's got he's got a really nice
hobby doesn't he invested $125,000 into
a freakin hobby
yeah we hope it's gonna break even yeah
we have great projections of breaking
even well my guys sits in my office and
says he has a great projection of
breaking even I have a great projection
of somebody else running his business
unit uh-huh
this is really bad I know okay I know
but he is not willing to part with it
yet he doesn't want to give it through
this fall but he can't pay his bills and
you're gonna get sued when you don't pay
your bills
I believe me I understand that I've done
everything that I possibly can
some people have said well why don't you
go out and get a job which I completely
understand I have two toddler boys so we
can't afford to pay the childcare and I
have a teen who has some psychiatric
issues that I have to take her back and
forth to therapy three or four times a
week and I need to Alison here's the
deal
when you called and you started the
question in the beginning you gave the
answers it's extra work it sounds some
things if you think that they the you're
gonna have to some turnaround in the
near future you know it's short term
he's got to work multiple jobs you gotta
sell some things you got to get through
the short term obviously we believe it's
a very poor investment option but you've
kind of you know made your bed at this
point and you're too invested into it at
this point if you're gonna returns are
right around the corner and so and
they're not you know willing to relocate
so you put all that together it's gonna
take some short-term him work in
multiple jobs and I really don't think
even rule in Fort Wayne Indiana from
December all the way to June without a
job making at least twenty five thousand
maybe thirty maybe forty even in a
different industry could have been
trained by this time I feel like the you
know your husband really needs to get
get it together on this one did he say
great did he serve in combat he did he
was hundred and first Airborne Division
active duty for about four or five years
and then he went to National Guard
Reserve for another six years I
appreciate his service to the country
and I just I'm not trying to be unkind
at all but his decision-making sucks
and that's just--that's as kindly as I
possibly can say this the the initial
investment was a bad idea to start with
when you're sitting with your family
thus far in debt and then not being
willing to turn loose or something in
order to relocate and create an income
enough to feed your family and take care
of the basic needs and the things that
promises that you've made it's just it's
it's very self-centered and it's not
working and so I I think you guys
probably need to sit down with a good
financial coach and get some help if
you'll hold on I'll have Kelly pick up
and see if one of our coaches will help
you guys and they'll have a little more
time and maybe that'll make them a
little more kind than I've been because
I really I'm scared for you guys right
now
hold on I'll have Kelly pick up this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right kind of better than
same room the channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you